دعم سعودي للفنان المصري بيومي فؤاد بعد
جدل مشاركته في موسم الرياض تفاعل واسع مع
حفل روائع بليغ حمدي واحمد العوضي يشوق
جمهوره للاسكندراني اليكم الابرز في
[موسيقى]
اسبوع حظي الفنان المصري بيومي فؤاد بدعم
تركي ال الشيخ رئيس هيئه الترفيه
بالسعوديه وفنانين سعوديين وذلك بعد حمله
الانتقادات الواسعه التي تعرض لها على
منصات التواصل في مصر مؤخرا والجدل الذي
اثاره حديثه للجمهور السعودي بعد عرض
مسرحيه زواج اصطناعي في موسم الرياض
وانتقاده الضمني لزميله الفنان محمد سلام
الذي انسحب من العرض ياتي ذلك فيما تتواصل
العروض المسرحيه المصريه في الموسم ومنها
مسرحيه تطبق الشروط والاحكام التي يشارك
فيها بيومي فؤاد الى جانب الفنان المصري
اكرم
حسني انا بحس ان انا مرتبط بالناس جدا اذا
كنت بطلع فن فانا واخده من الناس وللناس ي
الهى يا
حبيبي زي
الهوا حبيبي جيت
انا ل في الدنيا
دييه الا عشان احبك وكانت حفله روائع بليغ
حمدي الحدث الابرز في فعاليات موسم الرياض
الاسبوع الماضي وشارك في الحفل الضخم الذي
حظي بتفاعل واسع على منصات التواصل اصاله
وانغام وصابر الرباعي وماجد المهندس
ونانسي عجرم التي ابدعت في غناء انا بعشاك
انا
بعشقك
انا انا كلي لك انا واعتبرت المطربه
المصريه مي فاروق مفاجاه الحفل الذي اعلن
الفنان السعودي طلال سلامه تعذر مشاركته
فيه بسبب صعوبه وصوله لموقع بروفات الحفل
في الرياض على حد قوله في منشور له على
على منصه اكس وقبل اداء الطفل السعودي
وليد محمد ل سواح رائعه المضرب المصري
الراحل عبد الحليم حافظ بتفاعل كبير على
منصات التواصل
سوا
وماشي في
البلاد
[موسيقى]
سو سينمائيا شوق الممثل المصري احمد
العوضي متابعيه على منصات التواصل بلقطه
لنزال مصارعه ياخذه في فيلم الاسكندراني
المقرر عرضه العام المقبل وذلك بعد انتهاء
فريق الفيلم من عمليات التصوير مؤخرا تحت
اداره المخرج خالد يوسف عن نص الكاتب
المصري الراحل اسامه انور عكاشه ويضم
الفيلم على قائمه ابطاله الفنانين زينه
حسين فهمي وبيومي
فؤاد ونختتم الابرز بخبر رحيل الفنان
المصري عثمان محمد علي والد الفنانه سلوى
عثمان عن عمر 88 عاما بعد مسيره فنيه غنيه
وكان اخر ظهور اعلامي له في برنامج واحد
من الناس مع الاعلامي المصري عمرو
الليتي